I haven't been in a relationship in 28
years I want to feel that again I was in
a really dark place but everything
changed after I met my soulmate on
Instagram I have never that bar in
person so I've decided to go to Russia I
want to hear your voice and to see you
you want to say I I'm in love with
somebody from across the world and that
somebody is a girl I'm traveling 7,000
miles to meet the man of my dreams he's
a celebrity in Nigeria and he was a song
for me hello baby girl Lisa you know
anytime I took too often I always told
you that I love you holy
lonna lives in Ukraine and that our
communication has only been through
chapter XI right - see you soon so
excited and I'm writing back yes mmm
[Music]
things go well with Varia I'm gonna
propose to her I haven't been exactly
honest with Rose about my appearance
do you like ash is a relationship coach
and I question how he conducts his time
with women saw your phone had 68 text
messages that means them busy
[Music]
she's 70% good of what I expected okay I
feel comfortable getting feel
comfortable I don't trust the time I
feel like he's hiding something isn't
there something you have to tell me I'm
worried about you I don't think it's
safe to go with my health condition a
common cold can kill me it's such a risk
why are you doing this
I cannot deal with his female fans get
rid of these two-bit [ __ ] get it
straight but I'm not sure hoping yet you
want to throw it all the way what to
call please understand me I do not
believe in love
you lied to me I'm done this is book I'm
telling myself I should have been
smarter than this
[Music]